I told you earlier this week about
Donald Trump explaining why he doesn't
need daily intelligence briefings
because he's quote smart he's quote like
a smart person and we well first before
I tell you the latest news which
involves former CIA director Leon
Panetta I'll remind you what he said to
Chris Wallace over the weekend you are
getting the presidential Daily Brief
this only once a week well I get it when
I need it is that first of all these are
very good people that are giving me the
briefings and I say if something should
change from this point immediately call
me I'm available on one minutes notice
yeah I don't have to be told you know
I'm like a smart person I don't have to
be told the same thing in the same words
every single day for the next eight
years a bunch of people wrote in Pat
after we ran this story and they said
you know Trump said he's like a smart
person
he didn't say he is a smart person which
is just sort of a linguistic a
convention he said I'm like a smart
person but literally interpreted he said
I'm similar to a smart person but not
exactly saying he is a smart person and
I think that's more of a correct
assessment than just saying he is a
smart person I think you're right and it
seems that if we asked former defense
secretary and CIA director Leon Panetta
whether anything Trump said there makes
any sense the answer would be no he was
asked about this issue in a as per
Reuters and he said the following about
Trump taking the daily briefing only
once per week I've seen presidents who
have asked questions about whether that
intelligence is verifiable what are the
sources for that intelligence but I have
never said a seen a president who said I
don't want that stuff if we endure
another attack and the intelligence
officials had indications or information
regarding that attack and the president
did not want to listen to that for
whatever reason the responsibility for
that attack would fall on the president
Leon Panetta is completely right if
Trump makes it a habit of not taking the
daily intelligence briefing and there is
an attack against the United States it
would be perfectly reasonable to hold
Trump at least partially responsible
but don't delude yourselves rational
thinkers we know who is going to be
blamed for any attack during Donald
Trump's administration I'll give you one
guess
I'm sure you can get it right who would
be blamed if an attack happens during
the Trump administration Hillary Clinton
no Barack Obama close that would have
been the second option and and that's
it's a good assessment as well anything
that happens during the Trump
administration is going to be blamed on
the conditions left behind for Donald
Trump by President Obama and we have
evidence of this so remember President
Obama has been Brandt blamed for
Hurricane Katrina 9/11 these are events
that happened before he was president it
even happened at Donald Trump rallies
where people were blaming President
Obama for how he handled 9/11 seemingly
clueless that President Obama was not
president when 9/11 happened I did have
one idea of how we might be able to get
Trump to pay attention to the daily
intelligence briefings do them on
Saturday Night Live because Trump seems
to be watching that regularly or maybe
have it like an Eastern European model
working in a in the u.s. before being
authorized to presenting him the
briefings those are two ideas I have and
apparently the intelligence community is
trying to come up with a way to make
this information more interesting to him
yeah and I guess from what we learned
from a number of people who have
interviewed Trump if you're having a
conversation with Trump and there's a TV
on in the background Trump will pay a
ton of attention to that TV so maybe the
people who briefed Trump can come into
his office but then just play the
briefing on a TV in the background or
something like that
Trump's probably more likely to start
getting intelligence briefings daily
when the intelligence agencies are
staffed exclusively with people smart
enough to only tell Trump what he wants
to hear maybe Ted Nugent as the future
FBI director or something like that at
least Bush 43 was receiving his Intel
briefings I mean yes he ignored one
particular one called
Osama bin Laden determined to strike
within the US but he was at least
getting them right yeah that's the thing
I mean God forbid some sort of attack
did happen you would like to at least
look back and take solace in the fact
that you did everything you could to
prevent it and if you're not taking
every briefing that is offered how could
you possibly feel like you did
everything you could and knew everything
that you could have known this is a
systemic and fundamental danger I know
we'd like to joke around about it but
this is truly scary stuff game
fly is sort of like Netflix for video
games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDPS the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s